[Music]
boys
today i have left my job and i will now
be streaming
full time on twitch.tv forward slash
ludwig
welcome to the game boys oh my god lug
wig and chat
how are there that many cheese and a
name i cried to get there man i cried
for these views
dumb rich children that's how sly words
are he's right every streamer is a dumb
rich baby child
god damn and i'm one of them we are
going to be doing
our first ever uncapped
subathon and when i say uncapped i mean
if this [ __ ] goes
48 [ __ ] hours i will be live
for 48 in hours
this sunday we will start and i have no
clue when we will end
boys today we are doing you laugh
you lose the loser gets a tattoo on
their ass
it's because they laugh super cool how
many times do i have to ask
put me in my own [ __ ] lobby this is
the impossible meat it kind of looks
like
roast beef all right good luck one
[Music]
there it is this is the new record
on twitch for most subscribers of all
time
welcome to the fastest growing twitch
stream on twitch.tv
a baby majority of streamers out there
have one thing in common
they are unknown only a select few ever
make it big
and they all go about it differently
some are unapologetically loud
[Music]
others are quiet in a way that fills up
the room
a corpse
some will make you laugh this is fun
oh no
what is that what what have you done
others will make you cry last year my
dad
passed away from cancer and that whole
year for six months i was taking care of
him by myself
it was the hardest time of my life and
um you guys really like stuck around and
helped me through that
a few will try to help you understand
the world around you
a little better a liar pocahontas movie
i mean it's a direct rip of pocahontas
james cameron's avatar is literally
pocahontas
but with alien but no matter how they do
it
most truly successful streamers are
genuinely
having a good time
[Laughter]
sometimes it can be hard to quantify
what exactly makes someone popular
online but in the case of ludwig ogren
it's pretty easy he's charming
well-spoken
confident and recently broke the record
for the most
subs on twitch there it is
you were here this is the new
record on twitch for most
subscribers all time
holy [ __ ] that was insane
ludwig grew up in hollis new hampshire
graduating from a local high school in
2013.
it was around this time that he
discovered his passion
for video games specifically call of
duty
if you could see my face when i actually
accomplished
this challenge of only turning right it
it was like
pooping in um having an orgasm at the
same time
that's the only words like used to
describe it and the feeling was even
better than that
after moving to arizona to attend
arizona state university
ludwig got into super smash bros melee a
scene he would continue to be involved
in
for years to come every single person i
live with i met through smash
my streaming career started from smash
and
uh so it's just like a community that
that that spawned me i guess
you know outside of gaming ludwig also
tried his hand at stand-up comedy
at tempe late night comedy club where he
sharpened his
performance skills for his dream job of
being
a talk show host it's also what gave me
the legs
to feel confident enough to stream
there's a big difference between
bombing on stage doing stand-up comedy
and feeling like literally feeling the
people's silence when you expect
laughter
and then like streaming on twitch and
then like you drop a joke and
no one really little dubbies because you
guys leave
and i don't know when you leave which is
cool ludwig graduated from arizona state
with a double major
in english lit and journalism and mass
communication
in 2017. it was that same year that he
saw some
limited success competing in melee
tournaments taking sats off players like
chill and dude and vro but when it came
down to it
ludwig did a lot more damage as a
commentator
than as a player i could have gone pro
in smash if you gave me 10 years and
everybody else froze in time for a while
is it naruto how do i say it so i don't
get roasted naruto
naruto i think some people say naruto i
say no rude but i just say
i just say naruto he even put together
his own net play tournament
initially called the ludwig ogren
championship series
an event that has undergone a few name
changes since its launch
but has consistently drawn big names
like s-fat
mango and zayn to participate while
commentating a smash tournament in
california
ludwig met his veritable partner in
crime and eventual roommate
slime who invited ludwig to be part of
his podcast
bad melee i like to commentate because i
just like talking
and i have asperger's or you know like i
just
i just like speaking and
dipping his toes into the world of
competitive smash and podcasting
made ludwig realize that maybe being a
talk show host
wasn't what he actually wanted to do and
so during this time i'm trying to think
what is the quickest way to earn money
and obviously my mind went to
oh i'm a young boy i've got a lot of
free time to my spe
myself i've been honing my skills
i got a couple swimmers
how about i try the wonderful world
of sperm donation then again
there was also streaming something
ludwig had
wanted to get serious about for a long
time of course
it's a lot easier to get the ball
rolling when you're close to all the
action
and so ludwig applied to jobs in both
new york
and los angeles and when he got a
callback for a web editor gig in la he
packed up his stuff
and moved across the country to pursue
his dreams
unfortunately just as he was starting to
get used to his new life
ludwig got fired in the hr lady and
they're staring at me
there's no easy way to say this but
we're letting you go
i was like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i moved
to la for this job i don't have anything
and this wouldn't even be the last time
throughout his time in la pretty much
every job ludwig had
ended with him getting the boot i got
let go i
i was literally working part-time uh
marketing at a vape company while
working as a streamer
and i was like i'll keep doing this
until i have ten thousand dollars in my
savings account and then i got let go at
7k
so it hasn't been really much of a
choice i'm just not the best worker i
guess
and i didn't realize that until i got
fired five times
but ludwig took his professional mishaps
as a sign to focus on what was truly
important to him he'd been making some
modest strides on twitch
and so in february 2019 he decided it
was time
to wholly devote himself to his
streaming career
and i will now be streaming full
time on twitch.tv forward slash ludwig
algren
welcome to the fastest growing twitch
stream on twitch.tv baby
except that announcement wasn't entirely
accurate
ludwig's last gig was one of the jobs he
got let go from
but he had his reasons for patting the
truth
and i didn't want it to seem like i was
going full time
only because i got fired and i didn't
want people to pity me
or i didn't want it to overshadow the
idea that going full time was something
i actually wanted to do
which is true i did want to go full time
and that was it
i just finally had the balls to do it
fortunately ludwig not only had the
balls
but also the face that instantly put him
ahead of the pack
and before long people began to take
notice
i watch twitch like this right like i'll
be watching a stream i'll tune in for
like a couple seconds
i'll have them say my name and then i'll
like slowly get a boner from every
streamer saying my name and once they
say my name i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything they're doing anymore and i
move on
ludwig's stream didn't exactly hit the
ground running right off the bat
but in the next few months it picked up
more and more viewers
thanks in large part to his willingness
to try anything
once he's so happy over there he's so
happy so all right
good luck buddy
what the [ __ ] is going on
[Music]
that's how you do it let's go blah for a
thousand it's a big one from the hit
song mia khalifa the song goes you got a
boyfriend i bet he doesn't kiss you
he gonna find another girl and he won't
blank yeah
[Music]
smells like [ __ ] beyond just embracing
the weird [ __ ] his audience craved
ludwig did something else something that
set him apart from every other streamer
raging and screaming and just chatting
he put in the work to make sure that the
bits
skits and weird challenges were as
polished as possible
and it set him apart from his peers lud
would always go the extra mile for his
audience and
as the quality improved his dream of
becoming a talk show host
was actually coming to life just on
twitch
and when the global pandemic hit in 2020
forcing everyone to try and fill the
entertainment void in their lives
ludwig was right there to pick up the
slack
he is the greatest pokemon player of all
time i i am in disbelief if he gets to
burn here
he deserves 100 gifted subs oh
no way
who's gonna be mr 500k
[Music]
there it is now i can be true with my
furry self
sniffs ruff ruff what's your first owner
on the day i hit 500k you do this to me
he said he doesn't have time to teach me
he said ludwig okay uh teach lottery wow
i could teach a lot of
uh uh well uh what's xqc up to
apparently my viewer count too long the
latvian gambit advice
so his one piece of advice is so
shocking but now what do i do now what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to do hikaru i
don't give a [ __ ]
if gordon ramsay throws up watching this
i will be cooking steak
to the best of my dumbass ability see if
i was like
like cultured i would know where i am
but i'm not so i don't
mario but there's only so much
entertaining
anyone can do without feeling burnout
starting to creep in
and ludwig was no exception after nearly
three years of streaming
he was ready for a break on february
16th ludwig announced he'd be taking a
hiatus from twitch and youtube
to visit friends and family in his
native new hampshire
next month guys i'm going on break
i'm leaving i'm out pack the bags
dip it it was real it was fun wasn't
real fun
time for me to go bone voyage other
phrases that mean goodbye
sayonora think it's japanese but it
wasn't the relaxing holiday ludwig had
hoped for
on march 4th he had to undergo an
emergency
appendix surgery but i guess
appendicitis is like a really big deal
i guess apparently if your appendix
bursts and you don't get rid of it quick
enough you can die
or something i don't know i don't know
what people did like 300 years ago did
they just die
is that what happened they would just
die because of their appendix i guess
i don't know apparently shout out to
modern medicine i was born in the right
era
about a week after his surgery ludwig
returned to la
and to streaming full-time but it wasn't
going to be business as usual
he had something different in mind for
his comeback
we are going to be doing our
first ever uncapped
subathon and when i say uncapped i mean
if this [ __ ] goes
48 in hours i will be live
for 48 hours
72 the next one after that when you add
24 hours for another day
all of it this sunday we will start
and i have no clue when we will end what
ludwig didn't realize was
that 72 hours wasn't going to cut it
since the amount of time he'd have to
spend on stream
would increase by 10 seconds with every
new sub he got
and his viewers were determined to make
ludwig keep at it
as long as possible so i thought it'd go
a day or two
uh and then like three four days in i
was like oh
[ __ ] this might go longer than i thought
i don't have a boyfriend
you do twitch.tv has a boyfriend
just for a few days that's what you said
four days ago consider it a work trip
this is the worst work trip stop
subscribing you
monsters the uncapped subathon started
on march 14th and kept ludwig on air for
an entire
month the max amount of time he was
willing to keep going
to everyone who keeps subbing and
gifting the moment it hits one
i want you guys to know there's actually
no way for it to go under one
the way we have the timer set up because
it's a one it's like it's the timer's
like made of one piece
and uh and there's no way for it to go
under
it's called one piece rule 34 if you
look it up
what's up what are you doing for the
record guys romance is dead
no like fall like what'd you have for
breakfast today oh i didn't
could add some of this dick okay i have
gifted 5079 subs to mango
thank you wow lud
one eh i thought you got for your boy
you're no better than ninja you know
that
ninja ninja got 269k
subs and then he unsubscribed to me
when the cameras finally turned off on
april 14th
after broadcasting ludwig's life to his
viewers for a whopping
700 hours he had beaten the record
previously held by ninja for the most
sub-2 twitch streamer
okay yo yo yo
yo yo yo yo what's going on uh i don't
know if you heard
i just broke your record what you say to
me you little [ __ ]
i i just i just broke you
i no i i'm just saying i broke your
record
you know i i'm not saying i'm big time
it's not like i'm i'm [ __ ] leonardo
dicaprio i'm just saying that
i just broke the record i tell my
brother leonardo
you're trust god okay
i don't even know the peak number of
subs i had off the top of my head
so uh it wasn't that impactful i think
the entire journey was just what was so
overwhelming
uh and just streaming my life for a
month and how much support i had
and i happen to get a record which i'll
boast about
until the day i die even if someone
takes it but
it wasn't like i don't think it hits you
in any way i don't think it's that big
of a deal but most people would argue
that
having nearly 270 000 twitch subs to
your name
was a huge deal and the hype didn't
end with the subathon ludwig continues
to hold the record for most sub 2 twitch
streamer
while having one of the most active sub
counts on the platform right now
his fellow streamers reactions ranged
from
mildly supportive to downright insulting
what i told stans i remember vividly
telling sansa's like bro
both of us make like 10x what ludwig
makes right now
i'm pretty sure very soon
not only will he make more than us he'll
make more than us combined
i remember saying that and that was back
when he had like no viewers but i think
it's kind of cool to talk about
because i think ninja did it the old
stream way where like ninjas played
games 12 hours a day
whereas like love did like all kinds of
different content
so it's kind of cool like the number one
and two is like
ninja did it the old school twitch way
and led did it the new school twitch way
and it will come along it'll say yeah
like like the take place
it's not about being the first but doing
it better are you a terrible person for
weeks on end
okay so what are you going to do when
you're at the top then you're just going
to wait every time and you're just going
to
not innovate to just chill until other
people try things
but no matter what anyone had to say the
subathon made ludwig
a bunch of money a sizeable portion of
which he
donated to charity it earned him the
devotion of
hordes of new fans and cemented his
place
among streaming's elite i'm very
cognizant that if i have 20 000 people
watching me
you know a minute of stream time is 20
000 minutes
total of like human time which is like
so much
so i really don't want to waste people's
time
because i'm taking up so much of it and
with time becoming a very
real tradable resource online other
notable twitch personalities have
expressed an interest
in trying to one-up ludwig by running
their own
subathons but he insists it's not about
the numbers
here's the thing about subs i got him
it doesn't give you happiness i would
try something else records don't get you
happiness
so we should just leave this record for
eternity whatever happens with his
record going forward
it's undeniable that ludwig has set a
new benchmark for the rest of the
streaming community
he emerged from the primordial ooze of
early twitch
as part of a new breed of entertainers
one that sees streaming
as a legitimate calling worthy of as
much dedication
as any so-called real job out there
i think being successful at streaming is
preparing yourself
the best way possible for when luck hits
to be ready and to be sick because it
can strike at any time and if you're not
ready that might be your only chance
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages